buongiorno a tutti nel mio spiccioli
parlerò di responsabilità sale impresa
l'innovazione start up parlare di
responsabilità sarà l'impresa mi piace a
partire da una persona quello che vedete
nella foto e alessandro rossi un
imprenditore vicentino che nel 1870
quando fondò la sua azienda un'azienda
tessile della lanerossi creò all'intorno
intorno all'azienda tutte le
infrastrutture necessarie allo sviluppo
della propria azienda quindi le scuole
le strade gli asili le ferrovie tutto
quanto necessario alle famiglie e ai
lavoratori ma una cosa che mi ha colpito
particolarmente di alessandro rossi è
che lui selezionava i docenti che
avrebbero formato poi gli studenti che
sarebbero entrati nella sua azienda
quindi pensate che visione innovativa
che aveva della formazione
se questa se questa visione la potessimo
calare nel nella nostra scuola
nell'università italiana avremo uno
stravolgimento perché la formazione
sarebbe orientata al mercato quello di
cui le aziende hanno bisogno lui aveva
una grande azienda e nel mio progetto
l'uomo al centro abbiamo voluto
analizzare come le piccole aziende che
sono quelle tipiche del tessuto
imprenditoriale italiano in particolare
vicentino come che azioni svolgono un di
responsabilità storia impresa
le abbiamo elencate li abbiamo messi in
un questionario che abbiamo sottoposto
abbiamo tratto dei risultati
bene faccio vedere uno riassuntivo il
questionario non serve leggerlo è molto
piccolo
ad esempio un punto a quello dove
abbiamo analizzato quanti defibrillatori
c'erano nella provincia di vicenza li
abbiamo messi in una rete posizionata
sulla carta geografica e vedete può
essere molto utile sapere che il proprio
vicino la propria dall'azienda vicina
alla nostra
a un defibrillatore anche io posso
usufruire in casa
di necessità perché vi ho fatto vedere
la slide del questionario perché un
punto cui tengo molto è uno strumento
potentissimo se utilizzato correttamente
tutti voi credo avrebbe compilato nella
vostra vita con qualche il questionario
che sia in piscina palestra o un corso
di formazione però mai nessuno vi ha
detto com'è andato l'esito del
questionario e nemmeno sapete quali
decisioni sono state intraprese in
seguito ad analisi se utilizzato in modo
corretto nelle organizzazioni e qui lo
vedete con questo esempio dove c'è un
punto molto basso
quindi è quello su cui si deve
intervenire questa cosa va comunicata a
chi ha compilato il questionario
altrimenti la volta successiva non ve lo
compilano più è uno strumento veramente
potente come volevo collegare la
responsabilità di impresa con le start
up a mio avviso noi imprenditori abbiamo
una delle azioni di responsabilità sua
impresa è quello di fare qualcosa per le
start up e anche qui mi rifaccio a una
storia quella del professor fred ict
erman della stanford university che
pensate nel 1950 incitava i propri
studenti a realizzare il loro progetto
di business nei building appena fuori
dell'università diceva qui sviluppata il
vostro progetto perché mi sembra molto
interessante e pensa a detta dei suoi
studenti c'erano persone tipo hewlett
packard di cui conosciamo ancora
l'azienda come com'è andata
quindi un visionario un innovatore
assolutamente e prendendo questi due
esempi di questi due personaggi
io nel realizzare i nostri progetti
ho cercato di cogliere nella loro
essenza
abbiamo realizzato quindi per vicenza un
progetto che aveva chiamato primo miglio
1609 coinvolgendo tutti gli stakeholder
della città dalle banche al comune alle
associazioni di categoria e abbiamo
creato l'incubatore manifatturiero
manifatturiero perché il tessuto
vicentino e manifatturiero ci sono
aziende con competenze di ogni genere
quindi se i giovani avranno necessità di
qualunque competenza sappiamo che nel
settore plastica metallo o legno
qualunque cosa troveranno delle risposte
quindi sono convinto che qualunque
azione
noi facciamo in un progetto che cerca di
generare posti di lavoro e opportunità
prigioni credo che sia un progetto
positivo che avrà dei risvolti mi auguro
che lo sia appunto perché quello che c'è
in gioco è molto grazie e avanti
prossimo